[Musique]
bonsoir
avant de commencer à me présenter et à
parler avec vous j'ai demandé à tous les
adultes tous de bien vouloir faire un
petit exercice je vais demander à tous
adultes de remonter dans le temps et
d'aller chercher l'enfant de 12 ans
qu'ils étaient rappelez vous de vous à
12 ans
ça fait
bien aujourd'hui c'est à lui que je
parlais pas à vous mais à lui je sais ça
fait longtemps vous n'ait pas eu
il n'a pas changé vous avez vu
je m'appelle abdallah j'ai 11 ans et je
suis sans le sixième au collège je suis
un garçon en main tout ce qu'il ya de
plus d'un an et je suis passionné de
culture
deux livres ont marqué le petit prince
est le premier livre que j'ai lu et je
leur lis chaque année est le dixième
livre iron man in extremis parce que le
personnage tony stark a créé namur pour
sauver le monde grâce à la
nanotechnologie une autre même passion
quand je le lis j'imagine plus loin de
faire la même chose c'est de plus je le
lui que j'aimerais être ingénieur
j'ai beaucoup de rêves et nous les
enfants nous passons notre vie arrivent
et sont toujours essayé de rendre
possible du rêve on pense qu'il faut
attendre de grandir alors que c'est
possible d'organiser mal à vous
aujourd'hui
souvent nous nous limitons à rêver à
imaginer dans le tête commencera plus
tard
qu'est ce qu'on fera plus grand et on se
dit tout sera possible lorsque je serai
adultes ces cieux je deviendrai
quelqu'un mais en réalité on est déjà
quelqu'un on est sur cette terre on a un
rôle en vrai on est déjà là
on entend constamment les adultes parler
du futur mais c'est aussi notre futur
partage la même planète
le même espace le même temps et on a le
même cerveau notre cerveau a les mêmes
capacités que celui des adultes
un jour en écho un match
mais t'es marrant tort comme le
chauffeur tu oublies 3 à voir avec tes
enfants tu crois que tu as sauvé le
monde comme iron man c'est vrai je suis
fan des comics mais je n'ai pas dit
super pouvoirs mais il suffit juste de
regarder autour de nous et d'essayer de
trouver des solutions pour aider les
autres on peut aussi demander aux
copains de réfléchir avec nous ne pas
penser que nous sommes seuls et puis il
ya des adultes qui peuvent lui le petit
prince de saint-exupéry a permis à
beaucoup d'adultes ce n'est pas d'oubli
l'enfant qualité
quand la mère mais de lisser les 20
premiers je ne comprenais pas pourquoi
il était aussi important pour valmont
père
je me rappelle des chats oiseaux ski mon
père n'est pas peu dire
ma soeur il n'ya de 4 ans demande est
juste avant le voyage et faire semblant
de bourran cap est dans une fuite
j'avais envie j'ai vu ma mère à deux
contre un el hadj est né à ma fille
pourquoi tu veux faire semblant laurent
vrai tu peux le faire j'étais choqué
inaya trop heureuse mais moi chouk et de
là on a commencé à prendre le thème tous
ensemble en famille dans tunis
la semaine suivante nous avons été au
ski avec ce fameux tea time proposer des
univers musicaux hier me paul le père
des peuples
il était parti en belgique chaque jour
au bar nous prenions devant tout le
monde
le thé dans cette dig est en porcelaine
j'avais on dit quand je ma mère et mon
père au téléphone j'ai pensé qu'il
allait la raisonner et le dire que
c'était lente mais non il a trouvé
l'idée géniale je comprenais pas
pourquoi il faisait 5 ma soeur quand je
vais poser la question elle m'a tout
simplement répondu je ne veux pas
qu'elle fasse semblant là un rejet elle
a un rôle à jouer et je vais en train
d'apprendre sa place je n'avais plus
longue car j'avais compris pourquoi
c'est ce jour que je vous prie que nous
les enfants on doit prendre
je vais vous raconter comment cette idée
a changé ma vie moi ma meilleure amie
c'est ma soeur un jour nous étions en
famille et pour un projet associatif
on organisait un événement
en gros ne veut faire une activité
street art macérer mois suivant des
cours du pilote pendaison à un moment ma
mère nous a dit qu'elle ne croit pas
participé qu à cause de son handicap
pour broyer aux cervicales et donc
qu'elle fera des photos j'ai vu qu'elle
était triste voire trop trop déçu de ne
pas le faire et c'était la première fois
que je voyais ma mère ne pas essayer de
trouver une solution
vraiment c'était trop dur ongles jeudi
inquiète pas tu le ferais avec soin sur
pour trouver une solution
je ne sais pas si on a pris ce jour là
mais je le savais je m'étais suivant
j'avais compris ce qu'elle m'avait dit
avec son rôle à jouer
mon père était fier de moi il m'a dit
débrouille toi mon fils j'ai cherché des
heures savoir comment faire j'avais une
base intrigue mais qui ne répondait pas
la problématique
quand j'étais chez mon ami dans la
chambre de ma tante nema j'y trouve une
personne seule fille
et là j'ai compris ce que ma mère me dit
sans cesse ouvres ton esprit regarde
autour de toi fais des connexions entre
les limites et j'ai déjà passé c'est bon
j'ai trouvé elle m'a suivi direct
elle m'a dit moi je fais des plans et
toi tu manges tu un truc elle n'a pas
hésité une seconde
j'en ai parlé à la mère qui a elle aussi
suivi direct mais bon elle a su ma soeur
en titane dans ce gène est ma soeur a
maintenant six ans nous buvons encore le
sinaï
nous avons visité enfin blog à qui on a
demandé de réaliser l'objet entendu
personne dans ma famille ne pouvait
m'aider techniquement gc10 fierté
aujourd'hui d'avoir osé croire que si
des possibles est d'avoir cru en moi je
peux maintenant répondre à mon cousin
lui dire je ne veux pas sauver le monde
mais je puis des mondes
j'ai réalisé ce que cet objet
apparemment j'ai réalisé ce que vous
êtes obligé à porter ma mère mais aussi
à d'autres personnes cet objet peut
aider des personnes en fauteuil roulant
à faire du street art europe 1 leur
clôture
whiting n'importe quel bon bout ce prêt
en outre mesure
public nous sommes des enfants et croire
en soi il ne faut pas écouter cette
petite voix qui est en nous et qui nous
dit que c'est pas possible il faut les
tordre le cou c'est important de venir
son ami était encouragée selon m sinon
cette voie elle prend de plus en plus
différenciés
il ya une chose que nous devons surtout
pas devenir ces sept adultes qui dit
quand j'étais petit j'ai envie d'y être
il faut arrêter de faire sont bons car
demain on ne fera pas semblant d'être
adulte nous avons la capacité de
réaliser ce renouveau il faut croire
nous les premiers pour que les autres
prendre c'est comme ça quoi comment ça
qu'on sera aujourd'hui la dure qu'on va
devenir
et le monde de demain mais pas n'importe
quel adulte passants se donne un
objectif et une mission celle de devenir
n'est plus le responsable et humain cet
adulte maison jaune devenir doit être le
meilleur me de l'enfant connaît
aujourd'hui est qu'on ne m'aura de
rappel enfant de 12 ans qu'on a été
il faudrait être fiers des princes de
saintes à duluth et maintenant je
voudrais m'adresser aux adultes
si au début je vous ai demandé de faire
revenir l'enfant que vous avez été c'est
uniquement pour montrer à quel point
vous l'avez oublié et je suis sûr qu'il
vous a manqué on a besoin de vous
aujourd'hui pour vous et et y croire
vous devez me laisser la parole à notre
place dans le monde toute ma famille me
dit constamment à si je peux leur
dernière gm profite à plein
j'ai la chance d'être enfin la vie
d'adulte et dur
en vrai si j'ai aussi difficile pour
vous c'est peut-être parce que le rêve
ne fait plus partie de votre vie il vous
suffit de vous rappeler l'enfant que
vous avez été c'est facile il suffit de
le vouloir
les adultes et les enfants doivent
apprendre à s'entraider
vous pouvez nous apprendre à réaliser
nos rêves à être acteur du changement et
à préparer nos tuteurs par nous mêmes et
vous aider à retrouver l'enfant que vous
étiez
alors
on y va
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]